en 2020 le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines proposera près
de 40 dates jusqu'en juin à lionel
mateta bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
cet établissement leurs biens sur un
difficile de présenter toutes ses dates
on va parler bien sûr des temps forts
qui attend les spectateurs en 2020 on va
juste commencer par ces curieux
personnage qui nous entoure en fait
cessé il ya un spectacle j'imagine oui
c'est une exposition qui lie un
spectacle de turak théâtre théâtre une
compagnie qui a 30 ans et qui qu'on
accueille mois de janvier avec un
spectacle qui s'appelle un certain
monsieur top bar top bar bartok voilà il
ya toujours de la musique dans leur dans
leur spectacle est en fait turak théâtre
à créer un monde avec ses codes avec son
vocabulaire et tous les spectacles
qu'ils ont créés depuis 30 ans se passe
dans ce monde imaginaire et on s'est dit
que en présentant leurs dernières
créations
il pourrait être intéressant de plonger
les spectateurs dans ce monde avec tous
ces personnages avec toute son histoire
et donc les trois étages où les quatre
étages du théâtre sont envahies de ces
deux morceaux de cette histoire de la
thur acquis puisque le pays imaginaire
s'appelle nature à pied c'est pour les
enfants moi je suis pour les adultes
c'est un enfant et familiale et à partir
de 7-8 ans sans aucun problème et pour
un public familial bien sûr alors en
2020 on va bien sûr encore retrouvé la
musique du théâtre de la danse aussi
je pense notamment aux ballets de monte
carlo au moi c'est un des très très beau
ballet
internationaux avec le ballet de l'opéra
de lyon avec le ballet prennent stockage
avec le ballet l'opéra de paris d
antoine mais ça fait partie vraiment des
grands grand ballet français dont d
accueil avec un morceau d'histoire
finalement de la danse néoclassique dont
il ya des petites choses qui ont évolué
dans les costumes mais la chorégraphie
et la musique sont exactement la même
qu'il y a 20 ans 25 ans lorsque le
spectacle a été créé et ça fait aussi
partie du travail de cette scène
nationale que de se pencher sur
l'histoire de la danse contemporaine
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y aura de la musique aussi je pense
notamment à kery james par exemple qui
sera oui il va y avoir de la musique
avec kery james met de la musique
acoustique
ce à quoi il n'est pas forcément habitué
puisqu'il a décidé de reprendre une
grande partie de son répertoire avec des
musiciens est ce qu'il ya des très
intéressant dans cette formule et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'on a eu à présenter
c'est qu'on entend véritablement les
textes de ces 10e si on se rend compte à
quel point ces textes sont ciselés son
actuel parle d'aujourd'hui parle de lui
et on avait envie de l'accueillir dans
un autre contexte que dans le contexte
uniquement rap partager leur peine et
les ignorants diront que c'est un appel
à la haine ou de nourrie par la justice
en la dénonçant dans la maison quoi
qu'il dise tu cries après coup alors il
ya aussi des rencontres qui reviennent
chaque année ce sont les rencontres in
site est ce que vous ne vous rappelez
déjà le principe de ces rencontres le
principe des rencontres ici tu essaies
de décider d'un thème qui nous concerne
tous dans notre vie quotidienne et
d'éclairer ce thème par le par le biais
de tables rondes donc de parole de
scientifiques de professionnels par le
biais de cinéma on travaille avec deux
films on travaille avec nos amis et
voisins de l'ugc skywest et puis par le
spectacle vivant ça c'est notre coeur de
métier
donc tout ce qui se passe pendant cette
semaine là ça va avoir lieu cette année
du 14 au 21 mars
que ce soit les tables rondes sur les
films où que ce soit les spectacles sont
autour du thème en question alors on les
années précédentes on a travaillé sur la
question du temps on a travaillé sur la
question de l'humain demain
l'année dernière on avait travaillé sur
les questions de l'alimentation la
production la distribution et la
consommation
et là on va travailler sur l' on va
travailler on va
voilà on va se pencher sur la question
de la ville alors comment de la ville
oui la ville la ville et ses défis la
ville d'aujourd'hui la ville de demain
donc une dizaine de tables rondes
douzaine une quinzaine de
représentations graphiques trois
spectacles et puis une dizaine de films
à l'ugc je note aussi un autre rendez
vous ce sera fin avril il me semble la
reconstitution du procès de bobigny
alors ça va être sous quelle forme
finalement dans les années 70 il ya eu
le manifeste des 343 qui a été ensuite
appelé le manifeste des 343 qui
était 343 personnalités qui déclarait
qu'elle s'était fait avorter et aucune
d'entre elles n'a été poursuivi quelques
mois après une jeune fille de 16 ans est
poursuivie parce que elle s'est fait
avorter elle va donc voir
gisèle halimi avocate pour lui expliquer
la situation et gisèle halimi décide de
enfin ne comprends pas pourquoi quand on
est célèbre on n'est pas poursuivi et
pourquoi lorsqu'on est monsieur ou
madame tout le monde
hong lei la metteuse en scène qui a créé
reconstitution ce spectacle
reconstitution reconstitue ce procès à
partir d'extraits qu'elle a choisi dans
les minutes de ce procès fictif sur
scène et c'est ça c'est ce qu'il ya de
très intéressant c'est que les
spectateurs vont pouvoir choisir
en fait le procès où les témoignages qui
vont avoir envie d'entendre puisque sur
scène et dans la salle il ya quinze
comédiens que le spectateur choisit son
parcours à travers ses quinze comédiens
donc les spectateurs sont sous casque
par groupes de dix devant chacun des
comédiens fait qu'il dira qu'on veut
peut accueillir 150 personnes pour une
représentation qui peut durer entre 2h
et 3h donc c'est donc un procès presqu'à
la carte est un spectacle à la carte où
on pouvoir choisir ses spectateurs
évidemment encore beaucoup de dates
retrouvez j'imagine de toute façon sur
votre sur votre site internet pour plus
sobre voilà théâtre qui point org
merci lionel de masse et que vous êtes
le directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci à vous